mes chers collègues la parole est au
président Henri drincourt pour le groupe
UMP
sur le Président mes chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs les ministres ma
question s'adresse à Madame le Ministre
des Affaires sociales et de la santé je
crois que c'est madame Delaunay qui me
répondra Madame le Ministre en effet les
projections qui sont établies par le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites à la
fin de 2012 prévoit que notre système
pourrait atteindre un déficit de 40
milliards en 2020 je voudrais rappeler
que dès que la conjoncture l'a exigé les
majorités que nous avons soutenu en 93
2003 2007 2010 et en 2011 face à la
crise nous avons engagé des réformes
permettant en 2011 d'économiser
4,4 milliards supplémentaires ces
réformes je veux rappeler quand même que
vous les avez toutes combattu
dès votre arrivée aux responsabilités en
2012 vous avez rétabli partiellement la
possibilité d'un départ à la retraite à
60 ans engendrant un coût supplémentaire
de 1,1 milliard d'euros lorsque vous
étiez dans l'opposition vous promettiez
de revenir sur les réformes que nous
avons faites et vous déclariez ainsi au
mois de novembre 2010 l'âge légal de
départ en retraite reviendra à 60 ans et
là je l'égale de départ sans décote à 65
ans aujourd'hui le gouvernement nous
propose l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation et le maintien des 62 ans
cette conversion nous réjouit d'ailleurs
et elle rappelle que vous êtes quand
même toujours en retard d'une réforme et
ce n'est pas celle qui a été adoptée
hier en conseil des ministres qui nous
permettra de combler le déficit pourtant
le gouvernement n'avait pas été avare
dans sa communication des réunions
solennelles avec les partenaires sociaux
au rapport du groupe de travail présidé
par Madame Moreau on un projet courageux
et ambitieux patatras le choix du
gouvernement nous enseigne qu'il ne faut
pas confondre communication et actions
et ce projet annonce à l'horizon 2020
une économie de 7,3 milliards tandis que
le scénario retenu par le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites prévoit au
minimum
20,7 milliards à combler alors en l'état
actuel il faut reconnaître que ce projet
qui a été présenté hier se résume
surtout à une augmentation des
cotisations et à une véritable usine à
gaz concernant la pénibilité les
distorsions publiques privées perdure
les régimes spéciaux sont sanctuarisés
et donc si les mots ont un sens il ne
s'agit pas d'une réforme mais bien d'une
hausse des prélèvements qui s'ajoute aux
autres alors le président de la
République annonçait dimanche dernier
une pause fiscale en 2014 le Premier
ministre j'arrive corrigeait lundi en
annonçant que ce serait 2015
comment se retrouver dans cette
cacophonie qui croire alors madame le
ministre je voudrais vous demander
qu'est-ce que vous êtes intolérant c'est
incroyable je voudrais vous demander
avant que ne s'ouvre à nous plus
monsieur parlementaire bâcler par
application de la procédure accélérée si
le gouvernement envisage des régimes de
retraite merci autrement qu'en ce
délestant du problème sur les
entreprises les actifs et les retraités
pour vous répondre madame Michel
Delaunay ministre chargé des personnes
âgées et de l'autonomie
c'était monsieur le député monsieur le
sénateur pardonnez-moi de un cours je
vous prie tout d'abord
je vous prie tout d'abord de bien
vouloir excuser l'absence de Madame
Touraine qui est retenue hors de cette
enceinte qui m'a prié de vous porter sa
réponse dès notre arrivée aux
responsabilités comme vous le savez nous
avons dû engager les concertations pour
réformer et apporter à nos concitoyens
des garanties sur l'avenir de l'origine
de retraite et parmi elles la
possibilité de partir à 60 ans vous
l'avez vu pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt des garanties monsieur le
sénateur puisque vous
leur avez vous-même apporté l'inquiétude
et le manque de confiance vous avez
ouvert en grand les portes à la
capitalisation et à la privatisation là
vous avez fait le choix de la brutalité
et du passage en force nous avons fait
celui de la concertation et de la
discussion nous avons besoin monsieur le
sénateur de garantir à nos concitoyens
que demain la retraite par répartition
sera sauvegardée nous avons besoin
d'apporter des garanties en termes de
financement puisque vous avez fait
porter l'effort sur celle et ce qui ont
commencé à travailler jeune or nous
avons besoin d'un effort réparti mesuré
équitable nous avons surtout besoin de
mettre en place une réforme de justice
vous n'avez jamais reconnu la vérité des
carrières pénibles de celles et ceux qui
pendant toute leur vie travaillent la
nuit et portent des charges lourdes vous
n'avez jamais reconnu la réalité de ces
femmes qui connaissent des carrières
heurtées et le travail à temps partiel
vous n'avez jamais reconnu la réalité de
ces hommes et de ces femmes qui sont
confrontées au chômage et à la vie et à
la précarité de la vie professionnelle
quant à nous monsieur lefénateur nous
faisons preuve de détermination de
responsabilité et de justice